lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
ver el trabajo de otras personas sacando
derivadas y verificar que su
procedimiento sea correcto o en todo
caso detectar en donde se equivocaron y
qué es lo que deberían de haber hecho en
lugar de lo que hicieron entonces
empecemos con este ejercicio que nos
dice que natalia intentó encontrar la
derivada de x al cuadrado más 5x por
seno de x este su trabajo y nos
preguntan si está bien hecho y en caso
de que esté mal donde se equivocó así es
que pone pausa el vídeo e intenta
resolverlo por tu cuenta
bueno voy a suponer que ya lo intentaste
por tu cuenta y vamos a verlo paso por
paso por aquí en este paso simplemente
le está aplicando el operador derivar a
esta expresión que es justo lo que tiene
que hacer pero a ver veamos cómo lo hace
aquí natalia lo que dice es ok tengo que
tomar la derivada de un producto de dos
expresiones
y ella dice en este segundo paso que eso
es lo mismo a multiplicar la derivada de
las dos expresiones pero eso no es
cierto justo aquí tenemos un problema si
tomamos la derivada de la suma de dos
expresiones de la función f de x + g de
x esto definitivamente sí es igual a la
derivada de la primera función más la
derivada de la segunda esto de aquí sí
es cierto sin embargo si intercambiamos
la suma por una multiplicación esto deja
de ser cierto la derivada con respecto
de x de la función f de x por la función
g de x en general no es igual a la
multiplicación de las derivadas hay
ciertos casos muy específicos en los que
si es igual pero en general si es
distinto a la derivada de la primera
función
por la derivada de la segunda función en
general esto no es cierto lo que sí es
cierto es que la derivada de la
multiplicación de dos funciones es igual
a la derivada de la primera función por
la segunda función sin derivar la más la
primera función sin derivar la por la
derivada de la segunda función esta es
la regla del producto así es que por
aquí natalia más bien tenía que usar la
regla del producto bueno y ahora vamos a
ver qué pasa si natalia hubiera
utilizado la regla del producto en lugar
de equivocarse esto no es lo que natalia
tenía que hacer vamos a aplicar la regla
del producto a esta expresión y vamos a
utilizar distintos colores entonces por
aquí tenemos esta expresión y vamos a
sacar su derivada la cual es 2 x x
5 y esta derivada la queremos
multiplicar por la segunda función que
es el seno de x por seno de x ya esto le
tenemos que sumar la primera expresión x
al cuadrado más 5x y multiplicarla por
la derivada de la segunda expresión y la
derivada del seno de x es coseno de x
por coseno de x y esto es lo que
tendríamos que ver en este paso por aquí
estuvo muy mal que natalia multiplicar a
la derivada de cada uno de estos
términos en lugar de utilizar la regla
del producto y por eso le quedó esto en
lugar de todo esto que es lo que tenía
que que darle así es que su
procedimiento no está bien hecho y se
equivocó aquí multiplicando las
derivadas de las expresiones en lugar de
usar la regla de los productos bueno
vamos a hacer más ejemplos
aquí dicen que katia intentó encontrar
la derivada de 2x al cuadrado menos 4
elevado al cubo aquí está su trabajo nos
preguntan si está bien su procedimiento
y si no cuál es su error en donde se
equivocó nuevamente ponle pausa al vídeo
e intenta resolverlo por tu cuenta muy
bien ahora vamos a inspeccionar el
trabajo de catia aquí está tomando la
derivada de esta expresión y veamos que
también lo hace bueno pues parece que
está tomando la derivada de toda esta
función con respecto a lo que está
adentro del paréntesis la función de
adentro lo cual se acerca muchísimo a
aplicar correctamente la regla de la
cadena pero le faltó un paso porque la
respuesta que tenemos aquí no es la
correcta
el error se encuentra en este paso y su
error es no aplicar correctamente la
regla de la cadena por aquí vamos a
hacer un breve repaso de la regla de la
cadena que nos
sé que la derivada con respecto de x de
f deje de x la regla de la cadena nos
dice que esto es igual a la derivada de
toda la función con respecto a gm x y
eso lo podemos escribir como f prima de
g de x pero luego tenemos que
multiplicar por la derivada de la
función de adentro aunque tenemos que
multiplicar por g prima de x por acá
podemos ver a la función f como esta
función que toma cualquier valor que le
demos cualquier valor que pongamos
dentro del paréntesis y lo eleva a la
tercera potencia esa es nuestra función
f y lo que tenemos por acá es f prima
evaluada en jefe x esto de acá es f
prima de eje x pero le falta multiplicar
porque prima de x le faltó multiplicar
por la derivada de 2x al cuadrado menos
4 la derivada de 2x al cuadrado
utilizamos la regla de las potencias nos
da 4x elevada a la 2 menos uno que es 1
y luego también tenemos que sumar la
derivada de menos 4 pero ésta es cero
entonces aquí la derivada de toda esta
función de adentro es simplemente 4x y
la tenemos que multiplicar esto es lo
que le faltó escribir a katia para que
su procedimiento estuviera bien ok este
4x aparecería por acá también aparecería
por acá
así es que su procedimiento no está bien
porque no aplicó correctamente la regla
de la cadena pero bueno vamos con el
siguiente ejercicio
jorge intentó encontrar la derivada de
seno de 7x al cuadrado más 4x
aquí está su trabajo y nos están
preguntando si su procedimiento está
bien en caso de que no lo esté cuál fue
su error
bueno pues estamos tomando la derivada
de seno de 7x al cuadrado más 4x así es
que tenemos que usar la regla de la
cadena que nos dice que aquí tenemos que
tomar la derivada de todo esto con
respecto a la función de adentro y
multiplicarlo por la derivada de la
función de adentro pero si tenemos seno
de alguna expresión y estamos derivando
con respecto a esa expresión la derivada
nos da coseno evaluada en esa expresión
hasta aquí vamos perfecto pero luego nos
falta multiplicar eso por la derivada de
la expresión de adentro y esa la tenemos
por acá todo pinta muy bien la derivada
de 7x al cuadrado es 14 x
y la derivada de 4x es 4 entonces hasta
aquí está todo perfecto pero por acá
parece como que jorge hizo algo muy
extraño aquí tenemos la función coseno
evaluada en 7x al cuadrado más 4x y
luego estamos multiplicando toda esta
expresión por 14 x + 4 pero al parecer
por aquí porque se confundió un poco a
la hora de ver estos dos paréntesis los
multiplicó y suele suceder a muchos de
nosotros nos pasa este es un error clave
súper común con el que hay que tener
mucho cuidado uno de los errores más
comunes en exámenes de admisión a
escuelas es cuando estamos evaluando
funciones trascendentales como el coseno
el seno la tangente
muchas de estas funciones las personas
ven ok tenemos aquí coseno y tenemos un
paréntesis y al lado de ese paréntesis
tenemos otro paréntesis y el cerebro
salta e inmediatamente quiere hacer la
multiplicación de estas dos expresiones
entre paréntesis
pero eso no es lo que tenemos que hacer
porque aquí esta expresión primero la
evaluamos en la función coseno ya
después el valor que nos quede de esa
función es decir lo tenemos que
multiplicar por esta expresión de hecho
aquí es una muy buena idea agregar unos
paréntesis indicando que primero se
tiene que realizar esta operación si es
que aquí es donde jorge se equivocó y su
error es multiplicar estas dos
expresiones y tomar el coseno de toda la
multiplicación cuando en realidad sólo
debe de tomar el coseno de la expresión
del primer paréntesis bueno vamos a
hacer un ejercicio más
tomás intento encontrar la derivada de
la raíz de x / x a la 4
aquí está su procedimiento es correcto
sino cuál fue el error como siempre
ponle una pausa al vídeo e intenta
resolverlo por tu cuenta
por aquí parece que intentó aplicar la
regla del cociente vamos a checar si
está bien en la regla del cociente
primero tomamos la derivada del primer
término y lo multiplicamos por el
segundo término y le restamos el primer
término por la derivada del segundo
término aunque bueno con primer término
me refería el numerador y con segundo
término al denominador entonces aquí
tenemos la derivada del numerador por el
denominador menos tal cual el numerador
sin derivar por la derivada del
denominador y luego todo eso lo estamos
dividiendo entre el denominador al
cuadrado
así es que efectivamente tomás aplicó
muy bien la regla del cociente por aquí
parece como que tomás si simplificó bien
esta expresión
la raíz de x es un medio que puso como
0.5 por equis a la menos un medio y aquí
está por equis a la 4 menos
la raíz de x por la derivada que es 4x a
la 3
así es que efectivamente esto está
perfecto pero veamos si hizo todos los
cálculos bien por aquí simplificó esto y
entonces aquí tenemos 0.5 por equis a la
menos 0.5 por equis a la 4
y no espera es este término de acá
aunque ya ver este término lo simplificó
muy bien nada más que lo puso por acá lo
cual está perfecto y luego menos x a la
0.5 x 4 x x a la 3
esto se simplifica en menos 4 x a la 3.5
y ahora
bueno pues ahora todo está en términos
de x a la 3.5 entonces menos cuatro 0.5
eso es menos 3.5 pero estamos dividiendo
entre x a la 8 y 3.5 menos 8 si es menos
4.5 así es que todo esto está perfecto
tomás no se equivocó en ni un solo lugar
pero si tengo un pequeño detalle que
reclamarle a tomás no es que lo haya
hecho mal su resultado es correcto pero
lo pudo haber hecho de una forma mucho
más sencilla realmente no era necesario
que aplicará la regla del cociente y que
hiciera todos estos cálculos en los que
se pudo haber equivocado muy fácil
por aquí desde el principio tomás pudo
haber simplificado esta expresión pudo
haber dicho esto es igual a la derivada
con respecto de x de x a la un medio esa
es la raíz de x por x a la menos cuatro
porque x a la menos 4 es igual a dividir
entre x a la 4 hoy vamos a ponerlo con
colores esto es lo mismo que esto y este
es el numerador pero además aquí esto se
puede simplificar todavía más aquí no
tenemos que aplicar la regla del
producto porque esto es igual a la
derivada con respecto de x
y aquí como tenemos la misma base x nada
más tenemos que sumar los exponentes y
nos queda x a la 1 medio menos 4 eso es
menos 3.5 y ahora si lo único que
tenemos que hacer es aplicar la regla de
las potencias aunque tomamos el
exponente lo multiplicamos por el
coeficiente y nos queda menos 3.5 por
equis elevada a la potencia que tenía
menos 1 pero menos 3.5 menos 1 es menos
4.5 así es que tomás pudo haber
encontrado la derivada de una forma
muchísimo más fácil y tenemos la misma
respuesta pero este procedimiento fue
mucho más sencillo no es que tomás se
haya equivocado tuvo la respuesta bien
pero podríamos decir que se apresuró a
la hora de aplicar la regla del cociente
sin pensar que podía resolverlo de una
forma más sencilla